I have an announcement to make and I'm
not sure how to make this announcement
without freaking out oh I'm so excited I
can't think of anything else it would
make me more excited than being able to
attend this event and this is a
monumental event because not only is the
whatever is gonna be announced will be
announced that day and I'll be there
I'll be able to see it with my real two
eyes but this event is being held at the
Steve Jobs theater this is the first
event it is taking place there and my
body will be there my eyes will see
whatever there is to see and you guys
will also be able to see it because I'm
clearly probably going to blow up your
feed so they're not following me already
on Twitter or Instagram then you should
probably do that immediately and prepare
yourself put your alerts on unless you
don't want to be alerted every second
because it's gonna get crazy I don't
know what's gonna happen I have no idea
I have no expectations which is usually
how I go through life because I don't
know what to expect you never know what
to expect so have no expectations and
then anything that happens is incredible
anyway I don't really know what else to
say except thank you I mean thank you to
you guys thank you to Apple thank you to
the iPhone just my first Apple event
like I can't believe it I can't believe
it I can't even
what happened watchband am I gonna wear
oh I'll probably wear this one cuz it's
my current favorite so this Tuesday is
the event if you've missed the memo and
I don't know what else to say other than
I'm excited obviously yeah I don't know
it's what I dream about like I actually
have been having dreams about this
moment and when I checked my email and I
saw let's meet at our place
okay I'll see you there I'll meet at
your place I'll see I'll be there I'm
booked my flight now well guys that's it
I just wanted to make a video telling
you guys because I'm clearly beyond a
static about it and a lot of you guys
always ask me Justine are you going this
year and I'm like no I'm not I did get
an invite to wEDC and unfortunately I
wasn't able to go and it was for a very
good reason I went to see my favorite
band tool and as much as I love Apple
I'm also an incredible huge tool fan so
to be able to go see tool who rarely
ever tours and now to finally get to go
to my first Apple event at such an
iconic time at the Steve Jobs theater
for the new iPhone I don't know I don't
know what else to say other than make
sure you're following me on Twitter and
Instagram because I will be updating
that very very frequently but of course
if you're not subscribed to my youtube
channel do that I'll see you soon
[Music]